okay already from JK Rowling the author
of the book series that kept orders open
for another few years comes the movie
adaptation for people too lazy to read
Harry Potter or a wizard Harry when an
evil noseless freak threatens to take
over the world it's up to this boy
wizard his totally useless friend and
his superior in every way hard
ladyfriend to defeat him and when I said
heart I only meant in the last three
movies after she turned 18 her Purves
journey along as they traveled to a
magical boarding school where kids learn
potions spells and divination but not
English math or science where technology
seems to be frozen in the 19th century
replacing cell phones and the internet
with quill pens and owls and where child
endangerment is totally no big deal
my goodness
[Music]
seriously how are they not shut the
school down yet a franchise so epic it
took ten years eight films for directors
and two Dumbledore's to tell featuring
the one that started it all
the one everyone hates the one everyone
loves the one with shovel face the one
with the raging hormones
the one where Dumbledore dies for
spoiler alert the one who can skip and
the one that made adults cry like little
babies follow our heroes as they
transform from adorable youngster
struggling to act I can't be a wizard
too awkward tweens to barely legal heart
throbs to young adults pretending to
look like grown-ups Ron really let
himself go witness the magic that will
dazzle you with questions like if magic
is supposed to be secret you have risked
the exposure of our world why is there
door in the most highly trafficked
subway station in London why are all the
bullies in one house shredder and why
don't they just expel them and isn't it
disturbing that this rattle Ron's crotch
is actually a grown man really of the
excitement of acclaimed British
thespians yelling nonsense about a cobra
Felix Felicis
Gryffindor Hufflepuff Ravenclaw and
Slytherin battles that would have been
way cooler with lightsabers or if they
just moved around a little more and
Rupert grints dumb face
[Music]
starry Luke sky Potter ginger spice your
first direction forward Davis professor
hans gruber
claudio Miranda Harry old man Warwick
Davis Forest Whitaker Oh Dora Michael
Jackson Lindsay Lohan Warwick Davis
Vladimir Putin Larry King Gandalf the
game and forward Jesus Harry Potter so
Quidditch makes absolutely no sense
right 150 point ball that's just post
right there thanks for watching be sure
to subscribe you shall not pass I love
lamb they're eating her and then they're
going to eat me oh my god how's it going
royal ugly dudes Alison I love you will
you marry me what the hell is a
Hufflepuff